they think that heartbreak is worse for
guys than it is for girls and Tate had
this really interesting video where he
explained that because of the inbuilt
possessiveness that men have the thought
of their ex-partner now being with a new
partner is so painful that to them it's
going to be more painful than it would
be for a woman a heartbroken woman is
someone that deserves sympathy and
respect a heartbroken guy is like
[__] come on man man I'm not sure how
much I agree with both of those for me
but heartbreak was never about them
being with someone else the Heartbreak
was always just like the sadness of not
having that person that you are loving
and is loving you I'm not even thinking
about the next person because I'm
thinking about this moment I don't know
I think that that's weird that means the
only reason you loved your wife is
because she's not [__] other guys
that's a weird reason to love that
person I'm not sure that'll be the
reason that you love them but it might
be the reason why heartbreak hurts so
much on the other side of it I mean it
would hurt if she's sleeping with
someone else 100 but I wouldn't go there
until they did and I wouldn't be
heartbroken off of the hypothetical you
don't want them to stop wanting you yeah